- [Voiceover] So we have
an equation right here
that says negative two-y
times the expression
y-squared plus c-y minus three
is equal to d-y to the third
plus 12-y-squared plus f-y.
And what I'd like you to do
is pause the video and see
if you can figure out what
the variables c, d, and f are.
Alright, so now let's work through it.
So at first this could
look kind of intimidating.
We just have an equation,
you're trying to figure out
what these three variables
are, how do you do it?
And one reasonable approach
would be let's just try
to simplify what we have
here on the left hand side.
And to simplify that
we can just distribute
the negative two-y onto this polynomial,
onto the y-squared plus c-y minus three.
And then we could set it equal to what
we have here on the right and let's see
if we can match up coefficients.
So let's distribute it.
So first we could think about what
negative two-y times
y-squared is going to be.
Negative two-y times y-squared,
well that's going to be negative
two-y to the third power.
Cause y to the first times
y-squared is y to the third power
Alright, now let's multiply
the negative two-y times c-y.
Well that's gonna be negative two times c.
So negative two-c and then
you're gonna have y times y.
So negative two-c-y-squared.
And then we would multiply
the negative two-y times,
and we gotta keep in mind this is a,
we're subtracting three here,
so we could view that as a negative three.
Negative two-y times negative three,
negative two times negative
three is positive six,
and we still have that y over there.
So there you have it we have simplified
the left hand side of this equation.
And now let's see if, let
me actually just write
the right hand side in different colors
and then things might jump out at us.
So over her I wrote this,
the third degree term,
the y to the third term,
I wrote that in blue,
so let me write the y to the
third term here in blue as well
So d-y to the third.
And then I wrote the
y-squared term in magenta
so let me write the y-squared
term in magenta here.
So plus 12-y-squared.
And then last but not least I
wrote the first degree term,
this y term in green, so let
me write the first degree term
in green right over here, so plus f-y.
And when you see it like
that you see which terms
match up with (stutters).
With which terms match
up to which other terms.
So we could see that, look,
I have the third degree term here.
That has to match up to this
third degree term there.
So d, d needs to be equal to negative two.
So let's write that down,
d is equal to negative two.
We could see the second degree term.
This second degree term matches up
to this second degree
term right over there.
So that tells us that
this coefficient, the 12,
must be equal to the negative two-c.
So let's write that down,
negative two-c is equal to 12.
To solve for c we can divide
both sides by negative two.
And we get c is equal to 12 divided
by negative two is negative six.
And that makes sense,
if c is negative six,
negative two times negative six,
or subtracting two times negative six,
is subtracting negative 12,
which would be the same
thing as adding 12.
So then we get the exact same coefficient
for the second degree term.
I think you see where this is going.
Over here we have a six-y
on the first degree term.
Here we have an f-y on
the first degree term.
This f must be the same thing,
must be equal to the coefficient here.
So f must be equal to six.
And we're done.
And the key realization
here is you match up
the corresponding degree terms.
There's no way that,
well I don't want to get too complex here,
but the simplest way to address this,
is to realize, "Okay, I have
a third degree term here,
"I have a third degree term here.
"Well if I look at it very
simply the way I'm gonna
"get this third degree term here
"is using this third degree term."
And I just look at the
coefficients and say,
"Okay, they must have
the same coefficient."
And then we say, "D is
equal to negative two",
and then we keep doing that.